ثمانيه ايام فقط تبقت على تطبيق نظام
السياحه الجديد في السعوديه الذي يدخل حيز
التنفيذ في 25 من الشهر الخالي بهدفه
تطوير القطاع وتوفير بيئه جاذبه للاستثمار
وكانت وزاره السياحه اصدرت النظام الذي
يضم عشره لوائح جديده تشمل مجالات منها
مرافق الضيافه وخدمات السفر والسياحه
والارشاد السياحي مشيره الى ان اللوائح تم
اعدادها وفقا لافضل الممارسات العالميه
بهدف بناء قطاع سياحي منافس عالميا
نظام السياحه الجديد في السعوديه يضم
لوائح محدثه وملزمه لعمل مرافق الضيافه
والانشطه الاخرى من خدمات السفر والسياحه
والارشاد السياحي
يبدا التطبيق الالزامي للنظام والحصول على
الترخيص في 25 من مارس الحالي اذا ظهر ان
المرفق السياحي يشكل خطرا على الصحه او
السلامه العامه تتخذ اجراءات منها الاغلاق
واذا كان مخالفا فسيتعرض لدفع غرامه لا
تزيد عن مليون ريال لوائح النظام شملت
المخيمات ضمن المرافق السياحيه للمره
الاولى وحددتها بثلاثه تصنيفات هي 45 نجوم
كما اكد النظام على ضروره الحصول على
ترخيص لمزاوله نشاط الاستشارات السياحيه
سواء للافراد او المكاتب كما كشف النظام
انه في حال تعذر تقديم الخدمه المتفق
عليها يخير السائح بين توفير خدمه بديله
مساويه للاولى او استرجاع كامل ما دفع له
حدد النظام نوعين للتاشيره بغرض السياحه
الاولى الدخول لمره واحده وصلاحيتها ثلاثه
اشهر وال ثانيه تاشيره دخول متعدد
وصلاحيتها سنه
[موسيقى]
في استديوهاتنا من الرياض المختص في
قطاعات السياحه والضيافه ثامر الحربي
سيتامر حياك الله معك اهلا وسهلا تشرفت
على تطبيق النظام السياسي الجديد لو عدنا
لتذكر ابرز مميزات هذا النظام فيه وما
الجديد يعني وكيف يمكن توقع مستقبل
السياحه في المملكه بعد تطبيق طبعا تطبيق
النظام السياحي جديد راح يعمل عمله انه
نقل نوعيه في خدمات السياحه المقدمه من
ناحيه الجوده من حيزات المعروضه السياحي
كذلك في تعزيز البيئه الاستثماريه سياحيه
في المملكه اليوم عندنا طموح كبير جدا في
قطاع السياحه فبالتالي لمواكبه هذا الطموح
والتغير ليس فقط في المملكه وفي الاقليم
حتى على مستوى العالم حتى النظام السياحه
الجديد مواءمه هذا التغيير الحاصل سواء في
مرافق الضيافه السياحيه المقدمه او حتى في
خدمات السياحه اليوم نعرف ان السائحه اصبح
عنده وعي اكبر اصبح عنده يعني تخيل اوسع
بالتالي نحتاج ان نواكب هذا التغيير لدى
السائح من تقديم ماده جوده عاليه تجربه او
انشطه تجريبيه جديده في المملكه تواكب مع
تغير او تواكم مع الطبيعه الثقافيه
والطبيعيه اللي موجوده في مناطق السياحيه
في المملكه بالتالي كيف راح يتغير ممكن
نقول مستقبل قطاع السياحه عندنا احنا
متفائلين بشكل كبير جدا في التغيير اللي
راح يحصل في قطاع السياحي اولا من ناحيه
جوده الخدمات السياحيه المقدمه نستهدف ان
نرفع من جوده الخدمات السياحيه المقدمه
بالشكل اللي يضمن ليس فقط رضا سحب حتى
تكرار للزياره السياحيه داخل المملكه واحد
اثنين عمليه تعزيز التنافسيه في البيئه
الاستثماريه السياحيه في المملكه اليوم
نعرف راح يدخل يعني علامات تجاريه كبرى من
خارج المملكه وكذلك من داخل المملكه
فبالتالي تعزيز 100 الاستثماره تكون بيئه
عادله وامنه واركز اخوي خالد انها تكون
مرنه فاحنا اليوم حنا في مستثمرين موجودين
في القطاع السياحي وفي مستثمرين جدا راح
يدخلون في القطاع السياحي ومستقبلا
فبالتالي احنا نحتاج الى نوائ هذا التغيير
اللي موجود وفقا لنظام السياحه الجديد
ثلاثه نرفع في عمليه تعزيز الوعي ليس فقط
عن خدمات السياحيه بل حتى على المواقع
السياحيه اللي موجوده نحن من سمعه تلك
المواقع نحافظ عليها تكون مستدامه اليوم
حنا لا نستهدف فقط ان ننجح خلال فتره
قصيرنا كلنا هذا مستمر ومستدام في وجهاتنا
السياحيه الجميله داخل المملكه تكاليف
تراخيص حتى العقوبات البعض يتحدث بانها قد
تكون
منفره اكثر من ان تكون مرغبه بالتالي
المشهد ربما
يشير الى خروج فئه كبيره ربما من المهتمين
بهذا القطاع واللي كان عندهم
بعض العقارات ربما او الاشياء اللي ممكن
كانوا يستفيدوا منها خلال الفتره السابقه
ما رايك طبعا التغيير موجود ولابد ان
نواكب هذا التغيير كل مستثمره ومستثمره
بالقطاع الساحلي لابد انه يراعي ويعيد
دراسات اللي موجوده حتى يواكب هذا التغيير
ليس فقط النجاح قطاع السياحه في المملكه
حتى على مستوى المشاريع المعايير اللي
وضعت وضعت معايير مرنه حتى يعني الكواكب
هذا التغيير اللي موجود حتى تنجح تلك
المشاريع اللي موجوده اليوم اخوي خالد
اسمح لي نعرف ان المنشات اللي موجوده في
قطاع الساحلي ليس فقط في المملكه حتى على
مستوى العالم 80% منها من المشاريع
الصغيره والمتوسطه فبالتالي نحتاج لنرفع
عند الوعي عند رواد الاعمال الناس اللي
يقدمون الخدمات السياحيه لفضل على سبيل
المثال اليوم لاول مره في تاريخ المملكه
وقره لائحه وفق نظام سياحه جديد لائحه
مرافق الضيافه السياحيه الخاصه انه اصحاب
العقارات اصحاب المنازل يقدرون هم يشاركون
ساعه تجربته ويثرون تجربه هذا السحب
بالتالي حنا هذه فرصه ليس فقط للمجتمعات
المحليه حتى للقطاعات التجاريه انها تبدا
ان تفكر في عمل تقديم خدمه ابداعيه ثريه
للسياحه اللي موجود عندنا حتى ننجح في
ابهار هذا السائح وفي تجربه في شروط مشدده
استاذ محمد طبعا يعني مثلا انه والله شقه
لابد يكون لها موقف خاص اس بالاضافه الى
مدخل واحد البعض يقول انه هذه شروط مشدده
يعني الشروط اللي وضعت راعي احتياج ونظره
الساحل اللي موجود طبعا ليست بالمستحيله
انا اعتقد انه الكثير يقدرون يطبقون هذه
الشروط والمعايره اللي موجوده هذه من
ناحيه المعايير اللزاميه مع العلم وفي
وجود معايير غير الزاميه واختياريه من
خلال جمع النقاط لكن هذه المعايير حين
راعي فيها نظره السائح للسائح يحتاج انه
يكون لها الخصوصيه الاكثر يحتاج انه يحصل
على جوده اعلى يحتاج انه يحصل على حقه
كامل فاحنا اليوم ليس فقط حتى نحميه سائحه
اليوم حتى احنا نراعي في العمليه التجاريه
اللي موجوده في قطاعات السياحه انها يعني
تكون ناجحه تجاريه لان احنا نجاح والتجاري
يعني نجاح القطاع بشكل عام طبعا ربما بعض
رواد الاعمال او المستثمرين يواجهون بعض
المشاكل لذلك كانت في فتره 90 يوم اللي
راح تنتهي بعد ثمان ايام اعتقد ان الكثير
يعني راعي هذا الفتره انه يغير من وضعه
انه يحسن من الخدمه اللي يحاول قدر
الامكان انه يلتزم فيها الاسعار في السكن
في غيرها من الامور ترفع وتنزل بتبقي على
الحاله دائما واعتقد انه في كثير من الناس
تقول انه الاسعار عاريه جدا في الفنادق في
غيرها من الاماكن السياحيه فبالتالي هل
يتوقع التغيير قادم انا متفائل ان شاء
الله راح تكون في اسعار
يمكن في البدايه راح يكون في عمليه رفع في
الاسعار لانه راح يقل المعروض السياحه
اللي موجود لكن المستقبل مختلف تماما راح
يكون عندنا معروض يعني افضل جوده افضل راح
تكون في تنافسيه اعلى راح يكون في وعي لدى
المستثمر السياحي بكل تاكيد المستقبل
مختلف بشكل مبهر شكرا يعطيك العافيه يا
سامر الحربي المتخصص في قطاعه السياحه
والسفر شرفتو معكم خالد